and she joins us now with a preview
Nancy Grace thank you for being here
um I I want to start with the idea that
one of the reports that we got is that
when they wanted to capture him that he
said am I the only one that was arrested
what do you make of that and give us
your analysis of this whole case and
where we are today
there is an accomplice I want to point
out two things uh this guy has got a
master's degree in criminology he's
currently working on a PhD in criminal
justice yet he drove the getaway car all
the way and parked it outside of Mommy's
house are you kidding me another thing
we know about this guy he has been
described as obsessively vegan to the
point that he made his parents get rid
of their pots and pans oh no the bake
process in the dishwasher wasn't enough
they had to buy new pants that had never
touched meat what does that tell me he
is obsessive he is fastidious he's about
six feet tall he's socially awkward he
planned this whole thing out did you
notice the charges he didn't go into
steel he didn't go in to rape anybody he
went into that home with the intent to
kill how long had he been watching these
girls and as we speak Jason They are
tearing his Pullman apartment apart for
any notes or writings anything that can
match him up to this murder and I
predict they will find it
so the suspect here the the initial uh
profile that came out this pretty close
to the person that is the suspect of
this boy yes it is from the get-go we
said uh a male between 25 and 38 to 40
of white male because people normally
kill within their own race single which
she is as a matter of fact there's no
initial of a girlfriend an ex a fiance
even a high school girlfriend hasn't
been dug up yet so is this guy an incel
what was his motivation and let me
remind everybody the state doesn't even
have to prove motivation but I can tell
you take a look at this guy would it
surprise you to see him that face
staring in your bathroom window because
it would not surprise me and this is a
death penalty state
four bodies equals the death penalty
well I I hope that the parents have some
degree of closure and something in their
heart and their family members that they
get some degree there's no such thing as
closure
this guy will probably end up with a
life sentence unless a jury comes to
their senses and gives them the death
penalty these families and I know as
being a victim of violent crime you get
a life sentence for the rest of your
life wondering what your loved one went
through at the time of their death
it will never be over for them there is
no closure for these families
no it's a good point I bet do you
believe that there is or is not somebody
else out there the the police chief was
asked a direct question you didn't
exactly give a totally 100 percent
conclusive answer to that
you're so right Jason he totally dodged
it forensically it appears that there
was only one type of weapon used so what
am I supposed to think they handed the
knife off to each other no uh but could
someone have been a lookout did someone
help plan it possibly possibly but in my
mind highly doubtful
uh no murder weapon at this point what's
your take on that
he got rid of the weapon I think he
studied long enough getting his Masters
as soon as PhD in criminology to know to
get rid of the murder weapon hello but
still I'm I am confounded by the fact
that he kept the car maybe he couldn't
explain that away to Mommy and Daddy and
that car as you heard a few minutes ago
is going to be a treasure Trove look
it's practically impossible to clean
blood out of a car you can't get rid of
DNA with bleach you've got to use
something like muriatic acid such as
Black Swan he didn't do that I guarantee
you they're going to find something some
Trace in that car be it the front the
steering wheel the ignition the
hatchback there will be something in
that car
yeah it was December 7th that they put
out that picture at 3 45 in the morning
that car's going by but it obviously
paid I played a huge role in the
evidence in trying to track this person
down
it really did we long said find the car
our hopes were raised when a car similar
to this was found in Oregon with a
homeless person sleeping in it that was
not the car this is the car now we
understand that they have matched him up
to DNA at the crime scene it can't just
be any DNA because that was a real party
house and is there anything wrong with
that having a good time but DNA at
critical locations such as in both the
bedrooms on all the bodies or more than
one body possibly on the doorknob did he
touch the doorknob of the downstairs
girls that lived that night it's not
just DNA at the scene it's DNA at
critical locations in that scene that
will now match up to him where do they
get the match-up maybe like you heard
earlier genealogical DNA or maybe they
got his DNA from this four day Stakeout
we know that the cops have done did they
see him throw out a pizza or a
McDonald's coffee cup we don't know but
they were watching him for a reason
Nancy Grace love your perspective
appreciate your passion on this and
thank you hey Sean Hannity here hey
click here to subscribe to Fox News
YouTube page and catch our hottest
interviews and most compelling analysis
you will not get it anywhere else